man est ce que pour vous cette réduction
du nombre de parlementaires est une
réforme démocratique
c'est exactement le contraire c'est une
réforme extrêmement inquiétante pour la
démocratie pour les députés par exemple
aujourd'hui il ya un député pour environ
cent vingt mille habitants on aura un
député pour 230 mille habitants dans une
circonscription alors qu'on nous
explique que ça va permettre le
rapprochement entre les citoyens et les
parlementaires il faut en faire la
démonstration
244 sénateurs ça veut dire qu'on a deux
sénateurs et demie en moyenne par
département il ya déjà des départements
qui n'ont qu'un seul sénateur comment
est ce qu'on va faire la une répartition
rendre les citoyens égaux devant la
représentation parlementaire en vérité
tout ce qui est en train de se préparer
c'est l'abaissement du parlement on veut
réduire le nombre de parlementaires
réduire ses moyens on trahit a vite cédé
zamalek
renforcé une nouvelle fois la
concentration du pouvoir nous vivons
déjà centralisée parce que j'entends
parler de comparaison européenne dans le
reportage nous avons le régime est de
loin le plus présidentialiser de toute
langue a aucun pays d'europe qui
fonctionne avec intel une telle
concentration des pouvoirs dans les
mains du président aucun nous sommes le
seul à fonctionner comme ça à regarder
même les britanniques j'ai beaucoup de
choses à dire sur les britanniques et
leur politique actuaires et beaucoup
viennent de voter par exemple au
parlement un pouvoir de contrôle ni
totale sur les décisions concernant les
matières vous dit